- Oh (bleep) I can't with this sauce.
(light music)
- Hey guys I'm Matt, a
producer here at Tasty.
And today, I'm going to be
making a ton of tomato sauce.
I wanna see what's
better, sauce from a jar,
or two kinds of homemade tomato sauce.
So I'm going to prep my
station, and get started.
(light music)
There are tons of different
types of tomato sauce
available at the grocery store,
but for this test I
opted for a traditional
style sauce for it's simplicity.
Just pour it out, heat
it up, and you're done.
Idea for when you need a
sauce in less than 10 minutes.
(light music)
- What I notice right off the bat
is that it's super sugary tasting.
- It taste like dessert pasta.
- Not into it.
(light music)
- [Matt] This homemade
tomato sauce is very easy,
and can be prepared in under 30 minutes.
The great thing about
making your own sauce
is the huge amount of control you have
over the texture and flavor
versus with the jarred stuff,
you just get what you get.
With this homemade version, you can used
crushed tomatoes to make
it as chunky as you want,
or blend it to make it
as smooth as you please.
(light music)
Yes making homemade tomato sauce
isn't as inexpensive or as simple as
pouring it out of a jar,
but the extra effort
rewards you with something
much more flavorful,
and satisfying.
(light music)
- It has much more interesting flavors,
it's much more savory.
- Much more tomato in that one.
- I like that it's more
chunky than the other one.
I'm really into this (laughs).
(Jazzy music)
- [Matt] If you have lots of time,
and want a really fresh
tasting nuanced sauce,
low and slow is the way to go.
There's tons of methods
for making a slow simmered
classic tomato sauce so
you have plenty of room
for creativity and flexibility.
Whole tomatoes give you a
fresher, brighter flavor
than crushed ones.
It's a bit more work to
crush the tomatoes by hand,
but it will help them cook down quicker.
You can use carrots and celery in addition
to the onion if you want
more flavor and sweetness.
The longer you simmer,
the thicker and richer
the sauce will become.
If you really love the
flavorful punch of onions
and garlic, feel free to leave them in.
A food mill is a good
way to filter out seeds
and skin while giving
you a consistently smooth
and glossy texture, you can
also use an immersion blender.
(jazzy music)
From here, the longer it simmers for,
the better the sauce will get.
Some people will let their sauce
simmer for 12 hours or more.
Add the fresh basil as close
to the end as possible,
as it can lose it's flavor
the longer it cooks for.
Yes, it takes much longer than both
the jarred and 30 minute
sauce, but you end up
with a much fresher, silkier tomato sauce.
- Mmmmmmmmm, mhmmmm.
- See that just takes like home.
- The flavor feels more layered.
- I feel like you should put this in a jar
and sell that on the shelf,
because this is bomb.
(light music)
- [Matt] When it comes to
price, the jarred sauce is the
most affordable, but barely
beats the 30 minute sauce.
The jarred is also the most efficient,
taking a fraction of the
time than the others.
The homemade sauces offer
the greatest ability
to customize both their
flavors, and textures,
but the most important
question is, how do they taste?
When put to the test my co workers
overwhelming chose the homemade sauces.
They liked the 30 minutes
bold tomato-ey flavor,
and the two and a half
hours depth and freshness.
Ultimately, tomato sauce
is what you make of it.
Whether you have 30 minutes, or all day,
it's worth giving one
of these recipes a try.
(can pops) ahhh there we go.
(light music)